the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
assessment for this class was probably
the hardest thing for me at least how to
assign a fair grade students because at
the end of the day they're getting great
for this and it wasn't going to be an A
for effort type of thing it's actually
really hard because anything that
requires creative effort you just SAT I
mean I talk to you about this for a long
time like you don't want to crap on
people's creative efforts even if it's
just not very good very good um Jamie
and I talked a lot about this but
initially the rubric was very plastic
elements based like is this wallet can
you hear the audio okay and we just kind
of scrapped that and really went with um
there were four sort of principles to
the class that I talked about on the
first day which is like spark you know
what does it foster curiosity and that
was like a big theme that went through
every single assignment and how it
manifested changed assignment to
assignment you can see it on the rubric
you know kill your darlings like is it
concise enough there are a couple others
so that's how we approached grading and
we assigned them raw numerical scores
and we didn't have like an a is 20
Abby's 10 or 15 it was you know in
progress is from 0 to 5 and and like you
know steps moving forward is like five
to ten and then mastery was like 10 to
15 for instance so they would get
numerical grade feedback we gave a lot
of weight to their daily reflections so
that not everyone in the class I took
with a seasick I have question do you
think do you think grading should have
been a for effort because like in real
life and I didn't I didn't tell this to
you when we were planning the course and
I'm sorry but in real life like it
almost is a for effort if I show up to
do voiceover and I'm late and I'm sloppy
and like
very good job I'm not going to get hired
again and part of that is my technical
ability to do voiceover and part of it
is like showing up 15 minutes or late
being you know say you know being
professional all sort of stuff which is
kind of like does kind of seem like a
for effort I don't know any what do you
think well if I could so I i mean i i've
had to think about this a lot for the
course i teach at MIT and it's a huge
huge issue because so who should get the
better grade the person who has a huge
amount of talent and experience as a
filmmaker or video maker slough sit you
know just like you know just like lays
back throughout the whole course but
does a really nice piece at the end or
the person who never did has done it
before doesn't necessarily have a whole
lot on the ball when it comes to media
production but just works and works in
works it comes out with something that's
you know kind of mediocre because just
because by the nature of having never
done it before that that's really the
issue when you're dealing with
non-professionals that's when I me
because I completely agree with you I
made this the Woody Allen thing right
like most of life is showing up and it's
totally true but when you're dealing
with this huge huge learning curve it
becomes very very tricky so what we do
we don't do quite a for effort but we do
kind of allow an out you know if you're
for your project if your final project
which is a big part of your grade goes
completely haywire and just falls apart
on you you can write a fairly
substantial paper that describes what
your intense were why what your thought
process was what went wrong why it went
wrong what you would have done
differently and so essentially you know
you do have a way of supplementing or
making up for this in a problem you had
which was that you didn't know what the
hell you were doing which is a problem
well to the course values were
challenged and a lot of that manifested
in the rubric in the final project and
the graded assignments as is their
improvement from the previous iteration
is this person going outside of their
comfort zone and then thoughtfulness
like can you tell that this person has
integrated some of the things we've
talked about in class whether it's
through their blog posts or just like
office our reflections things like that
so that was built into the final grades
but then I would also say that the the
graded sort of quality projects and the
blog the daily reflections were were
weighted pretty equally so that if you
had a student which we did who had the
skills but didn't do the daily blogs
their grade would suffer a little bit
more just as much as someone who did the
daily blogs and you know just could not
could not host mr. in the end I did and
the end it worked out but by doing that
way like all the students who I thought
deserved great grades because you know I
knew they worked really hard got good
grades and all the students who were
very technically skilled still got
decent grades but you know it wasn't
like they got a hundred of anything and
it's always a tough challenge though my
math teacher used to say we'd be like
how are you gonna grade this test and be
like well I'm going to blindfold myself
turn around and throw darts behind my
back you're like okay yeah that's good I
just wish I could have written a paper
in chemistry class in college you know
to make up for the yeah I experimented
on south and here's what happened yeah
yeah yeah you know MIT students they
want to know like what do I need to do
to exactly exactly people are very
focused on yeah she meant do it yes
which is why I was very conscious of
like reading a specific of a rubric as I
can as a lot of sense especially when
as you said before because this this
isn't this is a form of art and there is
no right or wrong answer right how do
you feel like you can tell someone look
you didn't change anything from your
first draft so like you're going to get
docked for points on challenge like as
the group the rubric says or you just
straight-up didn't do a blog reflection
so you're getting a zero on that section
but at least I mean I do think that
there has to be something tangible to go
back to that you can't just sort of
arbitrarily assign a grade I will say
that I mean at the end of the day an
assessment a great assessment should be
a reflection or should be there to help
students improve and I do think that the
value in assessment and feedback came
from just sort of one on one when you
all worked with the students directly
and that's something that's not captured
on the open courseware class but like I
would stay with Jamie and Artie a
siri-like for at least two hours every
day after class just talking with
students and and you would work with
them and when you and john came to do
the workshop you know you just have
direct interaction with the students i
really think that's where the most value
came from I don't know if how you all
feel about that yeah I thought that
workshop was great by the way I didn't
get a chance to tell you but thanks
really nice yeah I mean I thought it was
just great to interact with the students
I think I mean I wasn't immediately sure
how you know how engaged they were but I
had some sense of it when I would
actually just sort of sit down with them
and they would directly ask me questions
and there was that sort of direct
engagement and I guess that that is one
would would question how how this course
could be done electronically or via some
kind of distance learning or or that
kind of thing because that yeah that
that seemed invaluable to me yeah kind
of personal contacts like how if you are
teach if you're a teacher at in Missouri
for instance like how can you teach this
course without a Chris without a George
and without a Josh I mean there are
versions of us in Missouri there
laughter oh yeah I haven't already said
something nice about line homestay it's
on camera but really like again you can
watch the open courseware stuff to get a
sense of just I mean they're just
fundamental facts I guess that you
should yeah come aware yeah yeah but you
know I like I would I gave a midpoint
survey to the students of like what
lectures have you found most helpful and
they were all like all of them you know
like Chris's was really helpful because
I got his perspective as a filmmaker
like as someone who you know was and
still is in the in the industry and then
you know working with planet nutshell
they were like oh I had no idea how to
storyboard and it was way more helpful
than just like watching a video of
someone do it like we were actually
interacting with them and like you're
hosting workshop like how do you give
hosting feedback not in in real time
like not live I don't know yeah I just
remember sitting down with with a couple
students and I think students were
running their ID ideas by by both of us
maybe me individually and and John just
giving sort of direct creative feedback
on well you know I think that could work
but have you thought about doing this
and then that would spur them to further
sort of creative thinking and that that
kind of interaction that relationship
seemed in value and the one on one
interaction I mean it's really you know
there's a lot of I've thought about that
too I mean maybe the equivalent of
crowdsourcing or something but but most
of the valuable experiences I had as a
student and that I think I've had with
students as a teacher are really not
even in the classroom but one on one oh
yeah I mean the most of the experiences
I remember more most powerfully are
being at office hours you know exactly
and having a teacher asked me like so do
you really think you're gonna be an
English major you know how
well in particularly in media or video I
mean where you're you know it's like you
have this work it's a piece of crap and
someone's going to sit there and help
you yeah turn it into something else and
just to learn what can be done to you
know to a script to something that's
that's been shot and write not edited
the way it could be means it's it's a
really powerful experience yeah yeah
definitely and so I wonder I mean oh
sorry to interrupt I just I just wonder
if the balance I don't know how exact
amount there the whole time but I wonder
if there could be more opportunity for
that kind of one-on-one interaction this
is very short right that's that yeah
yeah yeah yeah like some kind of
critique or workshop that like maybe we
all attended you know and gave thoughts
and for the students who worked with us
in production leak that was a lot of
one-on-one lot of one of us or like
three on one okay sooner but but there
again I mean that there's for production
week it was a clear it's like you don't
spend time you don't spend two hours
being like here's why you're hosting was
not optimal you just tell them what to
do to fix it quickly so you can get the
next shot you know but that that still
is valuable because you still see how a
professional does it and and like you're
there and you're doing it you know
you're not just sitting there watching
you are without you the show doesn't run
without the student that show doesn't
run so they have to do it you know a
couple of students who did science out
loud they waited to write their final
blog reflection until after they shot so
they were like yeah I wanted to wait to
see like how different it would be from
from the class and like even in that one
day I learned so much like more than i
did in the two weeks of the class right
just like being in that production
setting sorry go ahead does it and
something i wanted to mention is you
know again like this kind of thing isn't
scalable like we can't spend one-on-one
time for 20 students it was manageable
because there were only like seven or
eight of them at a given time thank
goodness
initially we were like yeah we're going
to blow it up a like 24 students oh my
gosh no it was it was a struggle to keep
up even though our teaching team is huge
just because it is such an intensive
process to work with them one-on-one but
what I I did want to make use of their
peer-to-peer learning and support and
somehow I don't exactly know how this
got faster but we we really had a nice
class environment the students were very
supportive of each other which was
really nice maybe because it was such a
small class but you know I during the
second week they would go off in groups
to shoot each other and they would give
advice to each other which was awesome I
would overhear some really great
directorial advice but I would also over
here some advice that'd be like no like
it don't make them host like don't make
them have that intonation and I wouldn't
say anything because I think it was
important for their learning experience
but that's what I mean by you know
there's only so much you can do with
people in the same sort of learning
sphere teaching each other well it's a
very short it's a very I mean I mean so
much of what this class is like is
characterized by the fact that it's so
short yeah because the cohort thing is
so important and I mean as someone who
you know I'll confess went to art school
I know sorry MIT people but so I went to
NYU the graduate film program through
your program so the first year of that
program is kind of like the first couple
of lectures in your class right that's
all class-based everyone you know I mean
you feel like your head is exploding
with all this stuff and you know you
know you're hanging on your faculty your
professors every word and you know it's
like kind of transformational after that
it's kind of pointless to go to class it
doesn't really matter what happens in
the class it's all about the cohort it's
all about what you do outside of class
and the help and support you give each
other as you make these seen our
iterative projects so it's it kind of
takes over and becomes the thing the
only thing you know the relationship of
the students with each
they're critiquing each others were
working on each other's projects rest of
it you know once you kind of have the
basics the basic conceptual framework
yeah it's like that's all everybody
doing after that yeah the problem is
because it's a two week or three week
class or even a semester or even a year
at MIT I mean these students are not
they're nowhere near expert not saying
that we are right right you know there's
only so so much that they can be aware
of with each other that it was a weird
balance to strike